[Music]  yeah peace i love peace  i'd be out of a job with peace  do we know each other  time  [Music]  reality reality  [Music]  it's changeable  where you want to be  that's the question didn't it every  universe  is different each one  unique  slow down a little bit there's a few  people in the room that don't understand  not me i get it  who are you the name's captain  carter  [Music]  i am the watcher i  observe all that transpires here but i  do not  cannot will not interfere  i guess i have to freestyle then  i said never flies solo  is that some kind of catchphrase  you had me worried for a second  journey to face the unknown and ponder  the question  [Music]  what if  [Music]  you